it feels like more and more after doing
this show and featuring all these
different leaders especially across
science and spirituality and the
marriage of the two it feels like more
and more that this was all made for this
exact
process that we're going through and it
is profoundly beautiful and being able
to experience it through this vehicle of
a body yeah it's just so majestic good
term you like that it is it is majestic
the he just all of this stuff is
majestic it's nice but it's nice to
remember that right people forget and
people think about the mundane of the
body
I remember the majestic of the
experience yeah yeah and when we when we
are really deeply immersed in the
majestic and the beauty of that we're
here going through this process and it
is not something that is just in the
brain intellectualized but it's deeply
embodied and then interconnected with
all of the other millions of species of
the other billions of humans in the
whole biosphere the entire actual
reality that we're in then we feel at
home
then then note the feeling is there and
then there's then all the other those
issues we were talking about they don't
come up yeah yeah